reporting now Trump V started his
campaign as a great supporter the best
president Generations Etc unfortunately
now all he does is disguise his support
in the form of deceitful campaign tricks
very Sly but a vote for VC is a vote for
the other side don't get duped by this
said Trump vote for Trump don't waste
your vote VC is not Maga the Biden
indictments against his political
opponent will never be allowed in this
country they are already beginning to
fall Maga if you thought that Trump
would permanently remain on friendly
terms with his political opponent well
then I don't know what to say to you I
noticed on social media as many people
noticed that lots of previous fans of
the ve suddenly in that moment as soon
as Trump gave his marching orders turned
on him like lots of people who thought
the VC was great suddenly decided that
he's awful